this whole house is
fear and violence if these guys don't do
the work they're probably going to get a
dog killed
the bulldogs are getting more and more
aggressive towards each other
pax bit his forearm
easy please it's okay okay
just look at his whole demeanor he is
scared and he doesn't have somebody
that's standing up for
i want him to get in movement and rhythm
with me you just haven't been taught
social manners
there we go good boy
i'm matt beisner and i work with
aggressive dogs
i promise you i'm not trying to hurt you
i take the dogs other people won't touch
you do not want to be a monster and
rehabilitate them with respect
trust and love i cannot believe how calm
he is
because i know there are no bad dogs
i'm on my way into work with a dog named
pax p-a-x
ironically enough his name is supposed
to mean peace
he has at least one bite apparently they
can't have anybody come in the home
unless he's on muzzle my process with
dogs usually begins with a house call
i come into your home it's about two and
a half three hours i just wanna sit with
you
listen to you observe what's happening
with your dog and then things just
evolve from there
i don't know how dangerous pax is really
gonna be
until i meet him
we have two dogs past and emma and pax
is the problem child
anything can make him snap
i feel very attached to him starting in
three months we started to see issues
nipping at people
and then at four months he bit somebody
after that there were
other incidents as well there's always a
chance that he might bite someone
it's really really dire we need to get
pax help
and it needs to be right now
hi hi hi horan beisner who's this one
this is emma
hi emma let's just sit down and
generally what i'm getting when i walk
into a house
tall i shave my head i wear dark clothes
i know i'm basically a walking trigger
90 of aggression in dogs is fear-based
and knowing that the question is how do
i set this dog up to feel safe
i'm not gonna hurt you and you're not
gonna hurt me
okay clearly he's pretty scared and
it looks like he could be really
dangerous how old was he
when you got him he was really smart
yeah one month four weeks old four weeks
old yeah
actually we found him online and when we
went there it was really sketchy his mom
was like pretty
amazing we actually didn't want to take
him that early because we wanted to give
him at least two months with his mom but
they were like we need to get rid of him
now and if you don't want him we're
gonna give him to someone else you may
be the only people that i've worked with
that got a dog at four weeks old
if dogs don't get what they need in the
first 10 weeks of development
the brain doesn't wire properly and that
you got him from
from a really dicey situation very least
neglected if not actually abused or
watching abuse
it makes sense that he would display the
kind of
aggression that he has do you want to
get that muzzle off so you can
let me know what you really think about
this clearly pax has some stunted
development that has left him crippled
with fear
and left him no skills to deal with that
stress ultimately
that can manifest in violence and
aggression
have you had incidents in the home with
him where he's bitten people there was
one time with each of us
he bit my arm once and then with her
upper leg uh-huh is it a puncture
yeah unfortunately there was
one time my friend was telling a story
and he got animated and put his hands up
like this
and pax just like lunged was it like a
one two or did he go
yeah it was a one-two it was there's the
hands thing you were talking about yeah
okay you can be agonizing for the owners
during a home visit like i'm just here
setting off their dog but in reality i'm
getting key information
what are the dogs triggers what's the
threshold for stress we feel very stuck
in life and with him
i feel bad it's like he just puts this
like darkness on everything and it's not
his fault
we care about him so much and we have a
very strong feeling that if we give him
up
or that he'll probably get put down
[Music]
yeah ran's not wrong about this the
majority of the dogs that get put down
in los
angeles are pits and pitbull mixes so
turning this around for packs
is a matter of life or death i want to
move to a different experience for him
and that is with me sitting here but
other than that i just want to see what
it's like for him it gives me a place to
start from
let's stay there for a moment okay
let me log into the leash thank you okay
there it is there's the stillness and
now he's
there goes the ears right he's ready to
pop at me
pax has been barking and growling at me
but now he's gone still and silent which
for a lot of dogs means they're about to
attack
he's definitely trying to work an angle
hand me that longing of the leash behind
your back
i promise you i'm not here to hurt you
okay let go i got it
i don't want to hurt you i just want to
see what we can do okay
in order to help defuse pax's aggression
towards me i approach him
with a calm energy and a non-threatening
manner let's sit down
we got to do this together okay i want
him to read my energy and downshift
there's the stillness that his pupils
are so dilated
yeah you want to lunge at me when i sit
down don't you but he's still
seeing red and he can't learn when he's
in that state and being edgy
yeah it's too much he's one of the more
dangerous dogs that i've worked with
definitely it's not gonna happen we're
just gonna keep going through the same
thing and it's gonna create more stress
for him i'd like you to put him back in
good boy pax good boy pax
i'll take that pax chose to downshift
and lay down it's small but it's a win
and at this point we need to keep
reinforcing that i'd be very
detached about how and when he gets
affection
you gotta wait till he's calm as long as
he stays calm
you can keep petting him neurologically
i want him to understand
that when you are calm and you stay calm
we will give you all the affection you
can handle and you're going to reinforce
what he needs most to be able to stand a
chance
to go out and change in the world which
is his ability to calm himself down
next steps we got to get pax out of the
home and into the zen yard to socialize
with other dogs
and then we can use that as a bridge to
get him back in the home
safely interacting with other people we
really need matt's help
it's like every day is another chance
that something bad might happen
we have to put him down that is kind of
like our last resort in our
last home bye kiddo i'm gonna walk by
i had a boy
want to talk about the presidents they
are five bulldogs named after presidents
in the home there is such regular
fighting that the owner
has a fight breakup stick on the couch
next to him the dogs break into a fight
and he pulls the brake stick out
breaks it up puts him back this is a
regular occurrence but they're actually
puncturing each other
and the owners have been bit
breaking up the fights there are rescues
some rescues some come from breeders
i'm gonna do a private session with them
and we will have them coming in
cool
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
calm down please i'm brian and this is
justin
and we are the parents of five bulldogs
[Music]
the five dogs are our children we love
their big paws and their
big fur and rolls and i just love having
these hippos
run around and knock you over in the
house
the problem now is uh as the days go on
the bulldogs
are getting more and more aggressive
towards each other
you think they're okay at times but then
within a snap of a finger
they lunge towards each other
we're concerned about the dog safety and
our own safety when they are
aggressively going after each other but
we're also worried about
other people's safety that come to the
house
right now we don't feel totally
comfortable in our home we're always
tensed up and stressed and not knowing
what's going to happen next
dog room's on the right here okay cool
do you have the the ones that are prone
to fight
they're okay so i separated to think
it's more of roosevelt who starts it
eisenhower will back off go into a
corner
so he then jumps first and then it
starts
truman the youngest one when we adopted
him he was a calm
puppy very nice and gentle he's now
starting to
jump into those fights hey hey hey
hey it gets a little scary there was one
time he bit me because he was right here
and drew blood stability needs to happen
in this home
if these guys don't do the work they're
probably going to get a dog killed
really the issue is between roosevelt
and eisenhower but it creates a madness
amongst the five
all day long is barking aggressiveness
and it takes a toll on like our personal
lives
that sounds really stressful
sounds like murdoch and lincoln are
innocent bystanders to this dangerous
dynamic that's happening with roosevelt
truman and eisenhower so i want to look
at these three troublemakers and see
what's really happening here
all right we're gonna play this one at a
time okay and i want
the two of you to ignore the dog
completely okay the first step to seeing
what the problem is
is teaching brian and justin how to
detach from their dogs
i start with roosevelt since he's
getting blamed for a lot of the fighting
let's bring the tormentor out
always when i come into the home i ask
the humans to ignore the dogs because i
want to see two things what does the dog
do with its humans and what's the dog do
with the stranger
right side of the face is that uh that's
from eisenhower yeah
that's exactly where they bite thank you
roosevelt we're seeing a little bit
buddy
on his own roosevelt seems like a
typical bulldog but there's something in
his relationship with his owners and the
other dogs that's driving him to
aggression
i'll bring truman out she's got to give
us some space come on out kiddo
he's the skittish one yep come on truman
he has a questionable history where as
we first brought him home he wouldn't
even leave his kennel
you could tell he was afraid come on
truman come on out you wanna see what
we're doing out here
i'm just here to help you it sounds like
things are a little bit scary
let's go see what's out there let's go
check it out come on
we're gonna go take a walk together
here's what we're gonna do i'm not gonna
make you do anything but we're gonna see
about getting out into this world
together okay
come on let's keep walking i'll walk
with you
you get hurt oh i can see you're scared
oh
my buddy i can see you're scared i'm
struck by how afraid
truman is truman is crippled with fear
all he wants to do is get back to his
crate it's kind of heartbreaking
bulldogs are not aggressive by nature
but if they're not socialized as puppies
it's likely they're going to become
aggressive his training is going to be
about getting comfortable and being able
to trust in the world
my next move is to bring eisenhower out
let's go sit down on the couch see what
happens
[Music]
hi
okay yeah
eisen
[Applause]
a lot of fear these dogs have a lot of
fear do you have any concern that he
would lunge at the cameras
i don't think immediately i think easy
please it's okay
isaac no i said no
isaac no isaac no okay eyes and hours
sphere is pushing him towards the edge
of violence
that's the theme of this whole house is
fear and violence in a multi-dog
household
a secure pack creates a safe environment
in a home like this
the sketchy backgrounds of some of these
dogs combined with insecurity means
there's jockeying for position
go ahead and get him back come on
the relationship between these three
dogs is toxic there are varying degrees
of anxiety and fear in this home
and the fear that is the strongest is
what leads to the most aggression
so if we create more security in the
home then there is less of a reason to
be afraid
[Music]
overall i was surprised to find out how
much fear
the dogs do have in causing the fights
so there's a few things i want to see
happen in the next month there's no
incident if you commit to this 30-day no
incident window
you just plan rotations so there's no
risk they're not together
we don't have a problem if we just take
fighting off the table
then we change the way we live with the
dogs they change their behavior the
hardest thing for me moving forward is
just staying consistent every day for
the next month
to help solve the problem i definitely
would like to see eisenhower at the zen
yard
i'd love to see truman there it would
probably be
mind-blowing for him yeah right and to
get roosevelt in there too
okay tell us what the plan all right
these dogs desperately need
supervised dog socialization if we work
to socialize them at the zen yard we can
control their environment
and then work to repair their damaged
relationship great thanks so much
yeah thank you appreciate it thanks so
much stay with the work
i really dig what happens in the home
sessions but the other part of our work
is what we do at the facility the zen
yard you can come on in and i'll show
you the yards
my wife brooklyn and i started the
zendog about six years ago the zendog is
a company that believes that there are
no bad dogs
most of the dogs that come into the
zendock are undersocialized they're
kicked out of other daycares
they've had really awful backstories or
they're just behaving nautily
i grew up watching mr rogers come on
friend
i'm gonna show you the board with all
the advisories of the dogs who are very
very dangerous
for example bl5d by level 5 dog that
means that it's a multiple puncture and
it's so severe that it requires
hospitalization
bite level 6 dog this dog has killed
another dog and they all show up here
like the island of lost children and bit
by bit we find a way to help them feel
more comfortable and more confident
when i helped the dog that nobody else
wanted to help and that dog changes for
life
the payoff is as delicious as 10 puppies
running around licking my face
today truman eisenhower and roosevelt
are coming into the zen yard for
boarding and training
justin and bryant have not been able to
keep the dogs separate and peaceful so
we've decided
to have them come stay with us for a
week so we can work with them in a
controlled environment
hey hey hey calm down
coming in with eyes an hour i'm starting
to work the presidents with my colleague
steph
she's a super talented dog trainer and
kaitlyn our manager is providing backup
i want to see roosevelt and eisenhower
together first since the owners said
that they're in the middle of most of
the fights
so i want to see for myself what they do
to trigger each other
but i create a safe boundary between the
two so this doesn't end up in bloodshed
roosevelt is not happy about his brother
coming in
eisenhower is clearly threatening
roosevelt right now same thing on my end
hard stare arms out yup just stillness
and staring like
yep i'm coming for you yeah my sense is
that if i let eisenhower out right now
off slip that he would attack roosevelt
agreed yep now we have a new and not
uncommon behavior from roosevelt which
is
i'm just gonna lie here but i'm gonna
lie here in a place
that actually forces your hand yeah i'm
gonna lie here and i'm gonna block the
doorway i'm gonna create my own boundary
and he's eyeing him right now right oh
oh
growling yep here we go
okay now the growling's increasing
because what's happening is roosevelt's
not giving
this is real time what happens in the
home wow
there it is scared me yeah it got me too
so if we don't have them secure
they're fighting right now it was really
interesting that roosevelt made the
first lunge even though eisenhower was
the aggressor
even after roosevelt laid down
essentially saying leave me alone dude
eisenhower wouldn't back down roosevelt
doesn't want to initiate a fight what
roosevelt has discovered out of
necessity is he has to defend himself
all right let's do a swap next i want to
see what roosevelt's relationship with
truman is like
okay come on out these two aren't
showing the same type of regression with
one another right now
so it's a chance to get them a little
bit closer together and see what's going
on
let's go for a smell what's your brother
really butt to butt i mean that's just
weird
it's not natural truman's grown up with
this dog
and they have no apparent desire to
actually
connect with each other and truman keeps
making eye contact and roosevelt keeps
turning away
um what do you think about going off
leash i feel okay about it
yeah i do too shall we yep
so the one thing for us to watch for is
anything that could become resource
guarding
easy yeah there's something punky to me
about what's happening here with truman
yeah cause there's a water bowl right
there this is not about you drinking
water truman this is actually
about who's drinking the water bowl that
you need to go drink out of
and he's walking differently there's a
posturing about it right
like you are lingering a little bit too
long kind of getting on my nerves truman
yeah and truths hey uh uh
uh uh uh uh
there's a posture about it right boom
boom boom boom
hey uh yeah
that is how you start a fight with a dog
that fights to defend itself that
doesn't want to be with you
okay and then he's cornered himself like
i don't feel
good this feels a little too familiar
yep
look at his whole demeanor yeah
his ears are back his head is low and
hunched and he's drooling
right and his eyes are hanging heavy
he's just
like this dog just shut him down hi
sweetheart he keeps making eye contact
though like help with everybody
yeah yeah he is scared and he doesn't
have somebody that's standing up for him
yeah
makes me actually see roosevelt quite
different
cause i just saw him and eisenhower as
these big bullies
my heart really hurts for this dog
during the home session
the owners blame roosevelt for starting
most of the violence but
he's actually the victim here let's get
him out of here and secure
and let's go right into eisenhower
truman i got
rosie truman you can have the yard buddy
coming out come on eisenhower let's go
so different right and he doesn't come
over and say hi to his brother
and truman's head is lower he has that
more
like i'm afraid i don't want to be in
here
now look truman wants to go yep okay
let's pause right there
that's how that looked to me yep truman
wants out
to get up and all he wanted to do is
stay in and punk roosevelt the whole
time
truman became a different dog while he
was alone with eisenhower
he totally shut down and was overrun
with fear
it's clear eisenhower's on the top of
this social ladder so we've got the
same cycle of violence happening in the
house because you've got
this one who started it on roosevelt
roosevelt began to have to defend
himself
then you get truman who says oh this is
how this operates we punk roosevelt
he's learning violence from eisenhower
for sure
it's not just a pecking order it's the
[ __ ] ladder but a good parent
does not allow their dogs to have these
kinds of relationships without healing
moving forward we need to socialize
these dogs separately they need to
realize that they can have relationships
with other dogs that aren't built on
fear and aggression but can be healthy
and secure
this didn't happen overnight so it's not
gonna get fixed overnight we
we are way further down the weeds than i
thought we were gonna be in terms of
their dog socialization but it's all
workable
so i know there's hope here
[Music]
the way we work with dogs is different
in that
we don't use any conventional training
methods coming in with packs
we're not using treats shock collars
choke chains prong collars
commands everything is designed for the
dog to be able to think for itself
because the dog that can think for
itself is not going to be reactive
this dog has got some dangerous issues
he was in blackout aggression in the
home
in the home visit we couldn't even get
packed safely out of the crate
today he's letting steph handle him so i
want to see if pax can remain
calm while being in the yard with
another dog coming out with mina
just because pax lives with another dog
emma doesn't mean that he knows how to
behave with dogs he doesn't know out in
the world
yeah he certainly seems intent
what's different about what we do
facility is we have dogs to help us
teach
dogs get to be with dogs that are good
role models that they can be trustworthy
it's fundamental to their experience in
being alive that they get to be a dog
and know what that's like
so uh why don't we give packs first
smell mm-hmm come here sugar plum
smelling another dog is the equivalent
of saying hello pax is gonna smell you
okay
i'm not gonna let you get hurt i promise
his breathing picks up and his eyes are
bugging out
just as rude and yeah pushy and like i
don't really know what i'm doing either
socialized
it's interesting that i got a few eyes
there
let's go ahead and get the hose out just
in case pax does decide to go after you
a hose is a great inhibitor we spray the
hose so that it's
near the dogs i just want the dog to
know that this is part of the
communication he's got eyes on me he's
terrified of the hose you bring it out
and he almost shuts down and doesn't
recover and there he goes he just saw
you go for it
and now he wants to get the muzzle off
now that he sees me as a threat
he seems particularly keyed up i got no
hose okay i'm sorry you got scared
that's what's happening to his fear
triggers there's a stiffness about him
that usually precedes an attack this dog
is a powder keg
there we go let's let this happen okay
okay okay
take the leash he just goes right for
the face
right alongside the neck too it's so
needy and so
desperate and creepy pax does not know
how to deal with fear
pax needs to learn how to calm himself
that's going to require detachment
and appropriate affection at home and
intense socialization here at the zen
yard
kid doesn't know he's not a bad dog
[Music]
come on kiddo let's go today we're going
to start socialization work with truman
we have a surprise party planned for you
this is a dog who's afraid of almost
everything and on top of that he's been
learning some very bad habits from his
older brother eisenhower
about how to interact with other dogs
whoo he is just a hot mess
come on bub good boy we're gonna start
him with huck
one of my favorites and one of our most
secure dogs
i'm surprised that he's this frightened
of huck it's
it it's like a stubbornness and he
disconnects immediately
good boy and he goes back into like his
shell good boy
truman what's happening here is i'm not
pulling
but when there's a sliver of release
which i can feel
good boy truman by not counter-pulling
when there's a good boy like that that's
it right there
gorgeous and so in spite of himself he
actually had a dog experience
and if i had let him dictate it he would
have been back in the crate and we would
have written this off and said it's not
gonna work
and not only did he just do it he did it
without us telling having to tell him
what to do
let's see if huck can smell you i'm just
gonna hang on to you here and huck's
gonna come over and smell you okay
so i don't have any tension on my hands
there's no tension on the leash
good boy huck good boy bud he's
breathing pretty heavy
but that was huck and nothing happened
huh now we want to up the ante a little
bit by bringing in licorice
he's still a secure dog but a bit more
high energy so i want to see if truman
can still stay calm
come here kiddo you want to smell
licorice
i'm telling you i asked him if he wanted
to smell licorice and he started moving
okay there's the lip
[Music]
come here kiddo do you want to smell
licorice
okay there's the lip there it is yep
i saw lip and i felt growl licorice was
a bit too much for truman to handle
licorice got in his space and gave him a
few playful barks and
truman shut down truman's pulling right
now cause he doesn't want anything to do
with being truman
he wants the truman show canceled and he
wants to get out of here
and go back to being nothing there's
just an overall
blanket of nerves and insecurity we're
going to continue intense dog
socialization to help truman feel more
comfortable in his own skin and
eventually with his own brothers
come on my loveboy
every once in a great while the zen dog
will foster a dog
dogs that have maimed humans dogs that
have killed other dogs
we commit to getting them the help that
they need so that they can get adopted
and put in a good forever home okay
we're gonna go meet lincoln
i say that there are no bad dogs because
i was that dog
when i started this whole journey i was
detoxing
i grew up making all kinds of choices
that put my life and other people's
lives in danger
i was given a second chance so i look at
the dogs as a reflection of my own
experience
oh this is pretty normal for me and i
the story goes that i look like somebody
that he was adopted and returned by
and apparently he was never the same dog
after he was returned i have a real
soft spot for lincoln he's exactly the
kind of dog that's a last chance dog
that's been misunderstood and a dog that
just
needs an opportunity to learn how to
relate with human beings
you can see his trust in amy immediately
he softens
yeah see you stay there and i'm gonna
step in and let's see what happens
it's okay it's just me especially with a
dog this reactive
detachment is the key to everything we
do if i remain detached and i don't
provoke him he will learn to calm
himself down
good boy lincoln you can hear the
pause in there
you could see how that made space for
his energy to change
if we change energy we change behavior
which is what he did
there you see it there's there's the
downshift
drops his head the barking changes
the body goes from that that tent state
that he's in and now there's a little
bit of movement there we go and he's
closer
that's the significance of what happened
for lincoln's day he got to face his
fear and work through it
if he can work through it with me he can
work through it with anybody else
good boy you big beautiful
bowling ball headed you're like a big
walking thanksgiving turkey
hey it's matt beissner today i want to
get a sense for how pax is progressing
i wanted to meet with the three of you
and
do some walking work you might say hello
we've been working with pax for the last
few days through some intense
socialization training you're doing
great mina
since pax went home his owners riddy and
rahan have been practicing detachment
making sure they only give pax affection
when he's called that way they don't
reinforce his anxiety and aggression
good point i'll be a little bit further
up the path
and i just want to do one pass by first
because i just want to see where pax is
at with me okay
okay sounds good okay cool i'm wearing
dark clothes and i do have a hat so i
know i'm already a walking trigger
so i'm just gonna walk by and we're not
gonna pay each other
any attention
wow he's doing a really nice job your
leash handling looks great by the way
you look calm and clear and uh i didn't
see a change in him at all no he just
walked by
yeah yeah excellent so why don't the
three of you start walking
and just pay attention ready to anything
yeah there he is shaking off the stress
anything that you notice i see there's a
little pole in there
he's rubbing reihan's life oh yeah to
get the muzzle off right
yep yep okay well i know it's a big ask
pax
i know i just dropped it on a walk with
you let's switch let's turn around
ran you take him and we're going to walk
together
so why don't the three of you start
walking
today i really want to focus on pax's
triggers
let's switch let's turn around ryan you
take them
and we're going to walk together as soon
as i joined the walk packs as kg
we're going to do it anyway kiddo i just
want to see you walk with me when he
encounters stress
he needs to learn to calm himself
instead of lashing out
you're doing good packs we'll walk
together
there we go atta boy pax
good boy pax i know you don't have to
like it but you're doing great buddy
this is subtle but it's a big moment for
pax he stayed connected with rahan
he kept moving and he was able to keep
his cool
what i saw today was promising in a lot
of ways it definitely stood out to me
that pax was able to walk by me
without reacting when he did start to
react
his reactions were not as intense he
didn't stay hot
as long as he used to he actually was
able to let it go
as evidenced by the fact that after all
of that
we end up walking together and pax
doesn't come at me
good boy pax good boy buddy we'll talk
about
what we can do next pax has to continue
coming to the zen yard for regular dog
and human socialization
otherwise he risks backsliding into
dangerous behavior
coming in with eyes an hour eisenhower
is the toxic alpha of this bulldog pack
at home
and he deals with the stress by bullying
and fighting like most human bullies
underneath it all he's literally
drowning in insecurity and fear
oh buddy this dog is broken-hearted and
terrified
come on nama i'm gonna bring in my
delicious dog nama
she's secure in her rank and she's gonna
show eisenhower the kind of dog that he
can become
we're gonna have you meet nama you just
haven't been taught social manners so
we're gonna
show you in our own clunky human way
what that's like
we're gonna come around this way and
let's come right in here and see what's
there
there we go good boy good boy eisen
and he looks at me like is that how i do
it he smelled it like he'd never had an
opportunity to do that before
even this i think you're actually gonna
try and throw a little
boom you see how unassuming and look at
he checks with steph to see if that's
okay right you do not want to be a
monster
smelling numb is a really big deal for
eisenhower and he couldn't have done
better for where he's at
i'm gonna hang on to you right here
cause nama wants to smell you
now i wanna have eisenhower get smelled
by nama which is gonna require a lot
more trust on his part
there we go there's the fear okay so now
we got growling
in his experience it's actually not safe
to have somebody come up from behind you
we need to keep working on this social
experience for eisenhower
help him get to a place where he feels
secure and trusting
and then he's got a shot at making
things work in the home coming out with
hike
coming in with packs
pax has been coming in for regular day
playing and he's making good progress
good boy hi bud thanks for sitting down
steph has been able to work with him off
muzzle which shows how far he's come
remarkable how different
already in holding with you than where
we were left off in the home
today i'm hoping he'll walk with me off
muzzle
why don't you walk next to me for a
little while okay hi pax
i see you i see you see me
since pax trusts steph i'm gonna try and
draft off of that energy and hopefully
we can transfer his trust in her to me
no my friend come on
i'll take it yep hi
let's walk up let's walk attaboy
there we go good there we go we're gonna
keep moving
i want him to get in movement and rhythm
with me good boy pax
i know that the momentum is gonna help
him stay unstuck
there we go we're gonna take this corner
too the momentum of walking helps dogs
move through their anxiety and
fear that's why movement is such a big
part of our training
good boy good boy pax this feels like a
big breakthrough for pax
it's amazing to me how far he's come but
his owners need to understand there is
no room for error
he needs clarity he needs direction yep
there's no room for wishy-washy kind of
communication
and he needs a profound amount of
respectful detachment
[Music]
oh good boy good boy justin is scheduled
to pick up his bulldogs today and take
them home
for you eisenhower in order to know that
it's safe to do that
they have to pass one more test here hey
how's it going
i'm caitlin matthews how's it going nice
to meet you in person i want justin to
observe
us reintroducing the dogs together for
the first time the only way they can go
home
is if they can get along with each other
i want you to be as quiet as possible
we want to try to be as kind of fly on
the wall as much as we can
so we'll just peek over and then let's
do it i'll follow you
cool i'm going to start with eisenhower
and truman come on bubs
oh i gotta write my mouth we're now
like we're spit brothers you know that
one nugget
bring him in if you would please go
truman
good boy let's go for a smell and see
okay we're gonna go around this way
oh that's polite bud that's very polite
there we go one
[Music]
two
let's go for a smell and see okay today
we are integrating bulldog brothers
eisenhower and truman for the first time
before their owner justin takes them
home
there we go one two
you would think that these dogs have
never done that in the home with each
other
like never had a healthy dog smell
interaction mm-hmm
wow good job truman come here my bud
let's go smell it yeah come on we go one
two there we go three there you go
atta boy atta boy good for you
come here come here love bug hi friend
there you go look at truman going in for
you truman
there you go good for you eisenhower
they've not actually had
direct interaction truman couldn't do it
and eisenhower couldn't be trusted
there's a lot of stuff in here that
wasn't happening before that's really
positive
that's good boy truman you did great
yeah let's have roosevelt come in so
caitlin you wanted to step in
and i'll grab rosie yeah we're gonna
have your brother roosevelt come out
okay
okay let's see what we got here okay he
is
wagging his nub good friend he's sweet
that's cool cause that's not what we saw
last time between those two
definitely more engaged a lot less
deferential
right you want to come in bud all right
okay bring him in
come on rosie yeah woo-hoo
look at you go good boy wow
i was kind of shocked watching them walk
into the pen i kind of thought that
they were going to revert back to the
bad behaviors but it was
nice to see them interact properly a boy
i feel like i'm watching a hippo run in
the wild for the first time
just
yes we can do a walk too he's not gonna
bother you i got him come on let's go
this i got him good boy eisenhower
sherman come on we're doing a bulldog
show here truman
hi truman let's get past the fear a
little bit good job
there you go there we go bulldogs on
parade
little dogs on parade dogs on parade
good job take a break okay fair enough
you know he's maxed out
so there's a lot of great things that
truman's demonstrated
eisenhower's you know smelling in ways
that he hadn't before
roosevelt seems way more comfortable in
his skin there's a lot of benchmarks
here for them
it's small it doesn't look like much but
we keep seeing these these
openings of possibilities they are at
the beginning of the end of fighting
ever again i totally notice a difference
in terms of uh smelling the other dogs
and
not being attached to me not growling
i feel great knowing they'll be able to
socialize with other dogs
and not act aggressively towards each
other it's amazing
you and brian got to keep doing the work
in the home yes
just do copious amounts of dog
socialization
he's got to keep coming with some kind
of regularity
the good news is that the recovery works
exponentially faster than the damage
does
if brian and justin can stay committed
to this work it is
absolutely possible that this beautiful
bulldog family can have a happy and safe
life together
which is all i want for them good boy
eisenhower
[Music]
hey how's it going all right good how
are you come on out you guys ready
hello mr pax today we're doing a
follow-up session with
pax it's interesting it's a slightly
different park
i immediately noticed a change of packs
coming in with packs
spark isn't as aggressive he's not
displaying as much fear
he's not lunging so i want to know how
things have been going
since matt came over well we've been
following a lot of the like only
acknowledging and reaffirming his
positive behaviors only touching him
when he's calm
good boy facts that seems to change a
lot
excellent but i'm finding he's making
those like right decisions like laying
down
sitting quicker so choosing calm
self-soothing behaviors more quickly is
what you've been noticing yeah i would
say like a week and a half ago
i was walking both paxademo and we saw
like three guys with like
five dogs and then they were like oh if
you want like can do like a little group
walk
around the whole park and he got a lot
of like socializing socializing
so it was really nice i love that yeah i
love that so much
have you ever had an experience like
that with him before no no
that's awesome i think that's like a
really big step for pax's end for the
both of you
to take with him the news on pax is
really encouraging
this dog was so reactive i got to see
this for myself i want to see him with
steph's dog amala
off leash you can take leash off ryan
it's great that you two are not engaging
because that's part of the makeup here
so this is his response to amala which
is to totally ignore
he's like i don't want to mess with this
girl and she leaves him alone and this
is a comfortable
place for them to be and that's it this
is all part of
a more mature pax a dog that is not only
practicing
consistently good impulse control but is
making decisions
that are about not engaging about
self-soothing
about being deferential he's not
fighting to get the muzzle off
you don't see tension in the body you
know there's not the eyes aren't weird
this i've never seen from pax i think
it's amazing i think it's an amazing
leap that he's made
he's clearly moving into sustainable
change
that dog came from a horrific place it
tells me that there's something
inherent in this work that can help even
a dog
that's been as crippled and
underprivileged as pax that he can be
safe in this world
he's not a bad dog and i want that for
him really impressed
with the way that you guys have to
remain detached this entire time with
the ups and downs
and this is taken yep i think that
you're making all of this possible for
him
clearly yeah i'm very proud of how far
past has come
every day he gets better when i first
came to the zen dog i was at like my
wit's end with him i was like
i'm gonna have to give him up i was
really really sad
zendog definitely gave pax a second
chance at a functional happy life
[Music]
you